what is up everybody it's anna mack here
for anime uproar and bro we just had
some powerful heartbreaking stuff in the
mha manga and we might have also just
discovered the one fatal weakness that
can bring all for one and shigaraki down
mark my words the events of this chapter
will prove to be crucial for the final
battle between shigerakin deku so we all
need to pay attention right now you guys
know what to do if you enjoy our mha
content and you want to see more in the
future leave a quick like and comment it
only takes a second but it really helps
me out with that youtube algorithm and
of course subscribing and hitting that
notification bell is a completely free
way to directly support the channel you
can also hit me up on twitter and
instagram at anime opera
finally this video will of course
contain boku no hero manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned first up i need to apologize
for a mistake i made in my review of the
previous chapter after endeavour lost
his cool and rushed at all for one i
thought that all for one had torn off
endeavour's right arm this was because
in the first image that we saw after the
attack endeavour's arm was blocked from
view by the blood splattering from his
wound and then in the next panel it
looked like endeavour's arm wasn't even
there just a gaping wound however it
turns out that all for one actually hit
endeavour just under his right armpit so
he injured the side of his body but his
arm is still intact my bad for
misinterpreting these panels and thanks
to everyone who pointed this out in the
comments of my previous video the new
chapter confirms that both of
endeavour's arms are still there but he
does appear to be seriously injured as a
result of all for one's savage attack
thankfully endeavour is not in
life-threatening danger as hawks
confirms a little bit later using his
wings hawks is able to sense the
vibrations of endeavour's breathing so
he knows that all for one didn't hit his
lungs on top of that as i mentioned in
my previous review endeavor should have
the power to cauterize his own wounds
using his quirk so he is not going to
bleed to death that said physical
injuries are not endeavour's only
concern he is emotionally devastated and
he is seriously concerned about his son
shoto but at the same time he is also
concerned about his other son toya with
an expression of absolute devastation he
calls both of them
my boys and it's honestly heartbreaking
endeavour knows that this entire
situation is in many ways his fault that
all the responsibility falls onto him
and he knows that he has to push through
all the pain both physical and emotional
in order to at least try to make up for
his many horrible mistakes and honestly
i have to say that endeavor truly is one
of the best written characters in mha
now i'm not saying that anyone has to
like him as a person because he's
clearly done some terrible things and
he's made horrible mistakes in his life
but at the same time he is clearly torn
internally about his past actions and
he's trying to make things right but he
knows that he will probably never be
able to actually do that and honestly
it's such a powerful and tragic
character evolution endeavor is deeply
flawed as a person and yet he's still
trying to be better even though he knows
that he doesn't deserve forgiveness and
that is exactly what a nuanced and
realistic character should look like not
every well-written character is perfect
likable and pure some of the best
characters are just the opposite and
endeavour is a great example of that now
hawks believes that endeavour will get
back into the fight eventually but until
then he needs to buy some time meanwhile
tokoyami insists that he and jiro are
qualified to help out in the fight and
even though hawks is clearly concerned
about their safety he agrees to accept
their help it's also clear that hawks is
proud of tokoyami's courage and resolve
and hawks honestly doesn't have much of
a choice here because lesbian real hawks
simply won't be able to hold all for one
off for long enough on his own for his
part all for one continues to troll
everyone he says that he doesn't have
any more time to waste here because he
has to keep his precious other self the
self inside of shigaraki's body safe all
for one then identifies jiro as the
weakest link and he attacks her with a
barrage of those creepy mouth things
which appear to be attached to some
equally creepy dark tentacles after giro
manages to get out of the way of all
from one's attacks hawks tries to cut
all for one's mask with a sword but this
doesn't seem to do much damage to the
mask at least not for the time being
nevertheless hawks is persistent he
instructs tokoyamanjiro to attack
together with him and to aim for all
from one's mask this mask is clearly
sturdy and it won't be destroyed easily
but it's still their best bet so they
have to focus all their attacks on that
mask jiro is going to use her own quirk
to generate sound waves that may be able
to crack the mask and as she prepares to
attack all for one directly she begins
to understand what deku and aoyama had
been going through all this time as they
dared to stand up to such a horrifying
and intimidating villain and speaking of
horrifying all for one's creepy arm
quickly continues to morph in grotesque
and unholy ways and he then turns his
focus on tokuyami and jiro he launches a
huge blast directly at them with one
hand while using the rivet stab quirk on
his other hand to fight off hawks all
for one's attack manages to cut off the
left earphone jack from jiro's ear which
sends blood splattering all over her
face i'm not sure if any of her actual
ear was cut here or just the jack and
i'm hesitant to make any conclusions
after i screwed up endeavour's arm in
the last video but we do literally see
that the jack was severed from her ear
so clearly some serious damage has been
done to jiro i'm not sure if the jack
will now be gone forever or if her
mutation type quirk can regrow it but
either way she does still have one jack
on her other ear and this has to be said
despite being injured giro does not
fault her in the slightest she says that
she doesn't give a damn about all for
one saying that she's weak and an extra
because none of that matters to her all
she knows is that all for one made her
friends cry
and with fury and passion in her eyes
she launches an attack called heartbeat
wall legato from her remaining jack
right at all for one all for one doesn't
seem too affected by this sonic blast at
first and he claims that all those
factors that shonen characters use to
hype themselves up including motivation
and spirit and ability are useless in
the face of his absolute power all for
one then advances on jiro pushing
directly through her sonic wave attack
and he looks fully prepared to kill her
but before he can reach her something
stops him all for one suddenly realizes
that there is something wrong on the
inside the wills of all of the people
whose quirks he has stolen have risen up
inside of him and they are trying to
stop him from killing jiro all for one
believes that new order might have
somehow triggered this reaction and he
is surprised that the will of such
weaklings is actually having an effect
on him and the attack from jiro combined
with the unexpected interruption from
the inside of his own body expose all
for one to a surprise attack by hawks
hawks has already managed to create a
slight crack in all for one's mask by
hitting the same exact location multiple
times and we can assume that jiro's
attack also helped make the crack worse
hawks then goes in for the kill slicing
at the same exact spot once again with
his sword hawks hits the crack so hard
that his blade shatters and then finally
we see that all for one's mask has been
broken a large opening appears on the
mask around all for one's right eye and
that is how this chapter ends this was
actually a really good chapter it had
some heartbreaking emotional moments
with endeavor and jiro and on top of
that what just happened to all for one
with his own stolen quirks seemingly
rebelling against him could become
extremely important moving forward now
let's be realistic law for one may have
been weakened by the destruction of his
mask but he won't be defeated right away
we've seen in the past that he can't
survive without the mask for at least
some time so this battle is not just
going to instantly end after this and we
also have to remember that all for one
plans for every eventuality and that he
has many backup plans so i wouldn't be
surprised at all if he has a backup mask
stashed away somewhere if so he will
surely try to retrieve that backup mask
and the heroes will have to find a way
to stop him but beyond the mask stuff
that revealed that the wills of the
original users of the quirks that he has
stolen are revolting against all for one
on the inside is a huge deal this means
that every quirk that all for one has
stolen contains a quirk factor with some
aspect of the original user's will
imprinted upon it kinda like one for all
all for one believes that new orders
somehow awoke these wills inside of all
for one although i'm not sure exactly
how that would even work well whatever
is happening this does appear to be a
new phenomenon for all for one judging
from his reaction this is not something
that he has ever experienced before
and that is why this could be such a big
deal and it could be crucial for
eventually defeating both all for one
and shigaraki i wonder if during the
final showdown between deku and
shigaraki we're going to see both an
external and an internal showdown taking
place at the same time kind of like the
battle between meliodas and the demon
king in 7 deadly sins i could totally
see shigeraki beginning the process of
stealing one for all from deku but then
the one for all vestiges intervene and
they push the wills of the stolen quirks
within shigaraki to start fighting
against him and so a massive civil war
begins to unfold within shigaraki's own
body and mind this would be really
interesting to see and i do think that
the story is probably heading in that
exact direction deku may not be strong
enough to defeat chicago on his own but
with the help of the one for all
vestiges and the vestiges of all for one
stolen quirks he may be able to pull it
off it'll be a team effort one big
question i had about this chapter is
that woman with the white hair that we
see trying to stop all for one she is
clearly the former user of one of the
quirks that all for one had stolen but
unlike the other people in that scene we
get to see a close-up of her face to me
this suggests that she might be an
important character and not just an npc
like the others i've seen some people
speculating that she might be related to
eddie because it looks like she has a
horn but i don't actually think that's a
horn if you look at that panel i think
that's just the space where all for
one's arm and torso meet because if it
was a horn it would be too close to her
nose that said again i totally screwed
up with endeavour's arm so take what i
say with a grain of salt anyway the
woman's white hair and facial expression
kind of reminded me of all from one's
brother yoichi so i wonder if this could
potentially be their mother what if one
of the first quirks that all for once
stole was his own mother's quirk and
what if the power of her quirk is what
made his rise to power possible we know
that over one was willing to mistreat
his own brother yoichi for the sake of
his own power so i wouldn't be surprised
if he did something similar to his
mother
let me know what you guys think who is
this woman with white hair and why did
we get a close-up of her face could she
be all for one and yoichi's mother and
is she or rather is her will going to
play an important role in bringing all
for one down i would love to get some
more info about the shigeraki family
backstory so i'm hoping that my guess
about all for one's mother is right also
what did you guys think about the
heartbreaking moments with endeavor and
jiro were their injuries permanent or
temporary and will they survive this
battle finally is all for one done now
that his mask has been damaged or is
this just the beginning of the fight let
me know down below you guys know what to
do if you enjoyed this video and you
want to see more in the future leave a
quick like and comment it only takes you
a second but it helps me out a lot and
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell if you haven't already
it's a direct and free way of supporting
the channel you can also hit me up on
twitter and instagram at animeopror i
want to give a big thank you to all of
our anime outpour patrons for making
videos like this one possible special
thank you to kyle salisbury this man is
an absolute mad lad and a disciple of
lore twigo himself and i can't forget
all of our the one tier patrons the ones
who rise above all other clans including
alpha sigma pate heffa the red-haired
fox hinokamian water the toasted chi
corey mcgowan the fallen chosen orihime
wukong dante tinnell and big buddhist
finally thank you also to our pro hero
tier patrons including the one and only
gilgamesh angel cruz alicia octor bonnie
parks fat boy games kaido might be a
duck alivania and anime s codem if you
guys enjoy our videos and you feel that
they provide value to you consider
supporting us on patreon as always thank
you guys so much for watching and until
next time see ya space cowboys